herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
ich bin gerade bei luca wir
wahrscheinlich nicht sehr konsequent und
die agraria das neueste video von k s
free cash out flüssige raus an der
stelle in dem zitierten video gemacht wo
er mit irgendwie ne freunde oder seiner
freundin gespielt hat metzger oder
youtube oder wer kennt nicht erreichen
auf amerika geklappt
herringen hat dort mit ich hab eine
haftung also jan metzger oder gips über
also es war wirklich so youtuber sind
und war ich würde ich heute eine aufgabe
an der ungar musste heute entscheiden
zwischen metzger und youtube deswegen
leute hab ich mir heute nicht gerne
youtuber ausgesucht und auch manager
ausdruck und du musst dann einfach
entscheiden ob ihm sogar ist oder besser
auf die idee gekommen oder oder zum
youtube mega mega idee das ist auf jeden
fall haben wir uns gedacht wir nehmen
diese kann auf jeden fall haben wir auf
jeden fall haben wir uns auf jeden fall
gedacht dass wir diese glorreiche idee
selbst auch nach machen wollen und wer
spiel heute youtuber oder irgendwas und
irgendwas kein beliebiger gegen
standbein suchen bei den versuchen aus
aber sollten wir wissen
du kannst natürlich vorbereitet bisher
erst ein bisschen schwieriger
und diese fehlt hier eine youtube oder
eine pizza sieht auf jeden fall wenn man
mal ein bisschen näher anschaut sieht
man auf jeden fall der kappe detail
wirklich das könnte ein gesicht
darstellen
wahrscheinlich ist er ja wirklich nicht
für dich kenne ich es nicht so gut wenn
youtube aus aber ich würde mal sagen
youtuber glaube in einer völlig weiß
aber schon mal auf youtube gesehen
leider ist kein youtube
das ist übrigens sorry dass das video
luca bewertet youtube heißt aber es
gehört zum witz ok mal jetzt bekommst du
von mir die nächste sache eingeblendet
und falls dieses wäre hier ist das
einstein oder ein youtube hat auf jeden
fall die form von menschen
man sieht auch finde ich das nicht mehr
machen sie ruhig zeit lassen wie sie
schwierige zeit und können einfach einen
stein sein der aufstieg in youtube in
der türkei weiter strikt ablehnt
ich glaube dass bis zum stein um stein
wirklich nicht was ich glaube also
erreicht
nein das ist mir dass es tatsächlich
schwierig war richtig schwierig und das
weißt du schon ist klar dass youtube
kevin brettl
leider hätten in der dpa
aber entweder youtuber oder kissen
wirklich kippen hast du gut ausgewählt
die auf cio.de hätte auch münchen sein
können ist auch der bequeme hause halten
aber ich würde dich sagen präsidenten
youtube oder ist er klein machen jetzt
mal direkt mit dem nächsten bild weiter
und zwar ist das hier ein stein oder
einen teppich youtube stein oder youtube
hier ein metzger oder ein youtuber stein
stein muskeln und deswegen werden mitte
märz gab es leider in youtube nein wer
werfen youtuber tatsächlich der beste
video wie erreichen weise mit seinen
mädchen spaghetti wie spaghetti oder
youtube argentinier der youtuber also du
hast nicht ob ich damit verraten dafür
und mit der allergiker sondern da kommen
die nudeln radwegen das feld spaghetti
haben
richtig bestätigt ich glaube damit hast
du heute gewonnen können dann leichter
abonniert und kälter ich machte
zwischendurch von paar ausschnitte
einfügen von judentum machen